i just got kicked out about
two or three weeks ago was that right
yeah
i got kicked out uh
some guy stole uh stole my shoes
and i
uh i met him at the gate and i told him
hey uh
you saw my [ __ ]
he said he
he said yeah i took your [ __ ] so what so
i flighted him
i just
got in a fight with him i mean lighter
means yeah going off on him yeah i've
ran up on him and i just took off on him
i mean
i got i got in a fight yeah
basically you know
yeah so adrian where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i grew up in
salgi california southgate
and uh tell me about your childhood
growing up you had both your parents
well i'm uh
in the beginning it was a fairly normal
home
well i thought it was you know and so uh
i was always a curious child
you know i was curiosity
always my mom said when i was little
uh
things like like your
devices or like stereos i was i would
put my finger
and without no screwdriver or nothing i
would i would take out the screws
you know what i mean which with just a
finger
my finger my my in my nail
as a little kid you know as a little
one-year-old two-year-old kid
yeah i was real curious
and uh
i didn't really know but i didn't really
know about drugs nothing until
probably maybe when uh
i started finding out about drugs when i
started seeing my dad
my dad's nor coke
of the restroom uh
counter you know
the sink
who had these lines
just seemed snored him
and i would hear that
and i was curious to know what that
noise was so i would go around the the
house
go to the window there was a window
i would climb a ladder
and look and look in and i see him
how old were you i was
i had to be like five six years old boss
right
now probably younger than that i wasn't
even in school yet
probably four or five
four five years old
yeah
and well
then um i got introduced into drugs
at nine years old
my dad my my brother uh my dad had a a
different uh
marriage before she he got with my mom
uh
he had three other uh kids he had a a
boy
and two other daughters my brother mario
my sister brenda and then my sister
denise
then the separated
my dad met my mom
which was way younger than his uh first
wife his first wife was older than him
by like 15 10 years and uh
so
there was a time when my oldest brother
i don't consider them have to be half
brothers
you know because we still got the same
uh
same blood running through our veins you
know
i consider it to be a
brother you know my brother
so my brother was messing up at the time
and
his mom
talked to my dad
and asked him if he could come live with
us
so he came
he came and stayed with us for a while
and that's when i first got introduced
to drugs
i was about nine years old which one
excuse me which drug methamphetamine
crystal at what age at nine years old
at nine years old
and uh
what is it what does a nine-year-old on
meth look like
a nine-year-old meth
i took the hit i took a blast out that
pookie
and bam i've shut up on the air like
like like a firework
like a firework you know me
for real like i took a blast and
boom i was gone
and uh i kept on tripping because i knew
my mom was gonna be looking for me
you know i mean so my whole trip was oh
my mom's coming looking for me i gotta
i gotta
get
high go hide somewhere you know get away
from my mom my mom and my mom my mom you
know how moms are
mom she knew mom yeah moms know
you know
moms and moms they
they give birth to you know
so they they they know
they know their kids uh and they know
they know where their kids go they they
know everything about you and my mom
knew exactly where to go to find me
she went on me and she said what are you
doing
hey wait what was right away she's like
what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you
i said oh no no no no no nothing bam
and took off again like a firework back
to the house
i didn't really get in trouble that day
um
but they knew i was on something was
wrong
did he continue
it continued
my brother uh
was at the house
a little bit longer than um
he uh started getting introduced into
wheat after the meth so the first time i
hit the math
bam it stopped for a little bit right
but i got introduced he was that's when
uh the cypress hill
that was in the cypress hill era
when the uh the dr green thumb era and
all that
i mean uh
so
weed was real popular in the 90s like
the early 90s i mean we've always been
popular right since the 16th since the
hippie days
but it was illegal it's always been it's
been legal until now day none
and today's modern day
god all type of things going legal i
mean
but
yeah uh i started i got introduced into
weed
the uh
the first uh uh
nickel sack that got sold to me
was from a cypress hill member
like i said i grew up in southern
california cyprus hill is from southgate
i mean uh
my brother went to school with all him
so that's how he knew him so my first my
first the nickelback of weed
was uh
was sold to me by by a trigger from
cyprus hill
which later on got kicked out of cyprus
hill due to the fact
that uh he started dabbling with
uh
narcotics which weren't uh
wearing uh
thc marijuana what they were used to
doing i mean
so they liked that and they kicked them
out you know
but yeah he he
he saw it trigger saw me my my first uh
his real name was edgar
and i don't know i don't i forgot his
last name but his real name was edgar
but he was a part of the cypress hill
clan you know did you uh finish school
did i finish scott i
actually i'm not
i never really went to school my whole
teenage years were involved in me being
in in uh
in in
in
jail yeah youth authority
at 13 i was in uh
i was in jail for uh
i went to jail for murder
and uh
that changed my life
you know
changed my life completely how's a 13
year old kid convicted of murder
uh a 13 year old gets convicted of
murder
because uh
a 13 year old had already been banging
for two years i started getting magnet
at 11 years old
you know what i mean
so
a 13 year old got convicted of murder
because
a 25 year old started shooting at a 13
year old the 13 year old wasn't having
it and shot him
you killed a guy at 13.
13 years old
how has that affected your life it
changed my life completely
you know
it introduced me to a whole new world
that i wasn't aware of
yes
does it affect you still today how do
you know i'm 31 now i'll be 32 in a
couple months does that affect you still
daisies
that's why i'm in this position that i'm
in i think i try and numb everything
that if i mean yeah you go to bed at
night put your head on a pillow and you
think about that i think about it every
day yeah every day in my life be hard
not to
yeah every day in my life i think well
you know
as the day goes by
you have these thoughts coming to your
head you thought about whether the guy
was asking for it or not it's about what
happened yes exactly
and basically i grew up either
gay or gay god
you know either you kill or get killed
i mean it wasn't going to be me getting
killed
i mean yeah so how much prison time have
you done
i've done three prison terms
after i got out of youth authority i was
when i got a youth 30 i was uh 18 going
on 19. i was about to be 19 years
got out
i met this girl
i'm at this growing hunter in there and
she got just to me by my ex-girlfriend
which later become became the
mother of my of my son
i have a 10 year old and a 16 year old
but before i went to hawaii
i had already uh
i had already implanted my seat in a
girl
which means uh i had already got a
girlfriend
you know
so before i went to youth authority i
got i was privileged to see
my daughter be born you know
yeah and uh
but right in the like right after i
ended up getting locked up for for that
charge you know
and getting busted and i
came out
um
i thought
i thought i was a
superman of gangsters
nobody could tell me nothing
uh
i was
nobody
nobody's gonna be able to kill me
you know i thought i was bulletproof
i mean that's and that's what youth
authority does to you you know
it puts you in a mentality where uh
you just think that you're unstoppable
boss
you know
so uh i gotta i get out with a meeting i
started
i started dabbling with drugs
i'm not doing too heavy drilling i'm
just dabbing with weed
meth
dabbing with me weed meth
anything i could get my hands on i was
doing
you know
and uh
so um
yeah so uh
i get out i'm
chilling and um
kicking on my homeboys
running the mug
out there doing things that i'm not
supposed to be doing as well you know i
won't say it on on camera but
part of the lifestyle basically the gang
banging lifestyle you know and
and our lifestyle you gotta uh
it's called putting in work you gotta
put in work you know and you don't need
to confess that anything here you've
done enough time already you know
but yeah basically you have to shoot
people you know what i'm saying to uh
to be able to uh be uh uh
uh
not appreciated by your peers but uh
accept it
i mean shooting innocent people or
shooting
no no no no no never never
never have i shot innocent any anybody
that was innocent never
not not me personally no but like
gangbang era there was yes they were
shooting just people on the street yeah
shooting people that were gangbanging
you know
gangbanging you know or we would go with
rob
rob
connects
that were selling big amounts of drugs
you know and infesting the neighborhoods
with drugs
and things of that sort you know in that
nature you know they making it somewhat
justifiable
some way is a perfect word for you know
someone because at the end of the day
is
is wrong right not right that's exactly
right right yeah it's not it's not right
it's it's wrong
i mean and
later down later down line as i
matured i found these things out you
know but at the time
i was a regular kid i didn't i think
nothing of it you know
my bad
i i thought i was doing what i was
supposed to be doing what i had to do
you know
you ever put the water ball down yeah
that's nice
thank you
sorry about that the problem is it's
easy
easy to fix um
so the prison
time gave you time to think about all
this and
reconsider exactly a mature pre pre oh
all prison did for me
uh which was in a positive manner
which i believe was mature me
you know
taking me from my
uh
from being a teenager and
adolescent to being a grown man you know
that's all prison did for me other than
that
i believe prison just makes you worse
you know because you come out back into
the community you just
it's a like a trophy like oh
yeah
you get uh
my things
yeah it's like a trophy
you know
you're proud of your prison time excuse
me you're proud of your prison time at
the time
at the time yes i was it's a badge of
honor yes exactly exactly it's a badge
of honor exactly it's a trophy
you know but now that i look back on it
now that now
i realized
man i wish i would have gone on a
different route
you know
did you have any role models as a kid
like your dad was
well my dad my dad really he used to
beat me up and you know my
uh dcfs got into the picture and stuff
like that you know
uh basically social services
and my dad got out of my life
when i was about 10 years old
10
yeah he
10 years old he was out of my life did
you have any positive role models in
your life my homies
my own boys my friends my brother you
know
not which were which weren't positive
right were there were negative role
models
i saw no i didn't have no one
that's what i'm certain to learn is a
huge huge problem yes i have i have no
positive role models
you know i mean
but then again we don't know those
things at the time it's not your fault
well we don't know these things at the
time we just and it's not their fault
either you know
they they just
they grow up probably the same way you
know
they don't know they don't know they're
influencing anybody at the time you know
it's not something that somebody thinks
about not well not in in my way of
living
and the way i grew up you know people
don't sit down and actually think about
these things because there are
everybody's out there your highest [ __ ]
you know like uh excuse my language
everybody's out there hi hi
drunk
why not you know different things
you know
so
so today you're you're aware you're
living on the street i'm living on the
street right now let's hear right yeah
it's good roll how long you been here
this time i've been here about a week or
two
but i've lived here before
yeah i lived here before i was out here
with my uncle
my uncle rest in peace and we used to
stay right here off town
in between six and seven right right in
front of the fire hydrant
we stayed right there for uh about a
good year
my uncle ended up passing away though he
uh
heroin addict as well
he ended up gaining an abscess on his
hand which blew up
like a mickey mouse hand
blew up like a mickey mouse hand
and uh kept on saying people kept on
saying i'm uh i was in jail at the time
people kept on saying i'm uh
too great to get to go to the doctor
that he's gonna
he
is gonna be this poisonous you know
glennapsis
is basically an infection
which makes your uh
body blow up you know your skin blow up
and that
if that infection bursts it's like a
wobble like a blob of infection nothing
plus in there you know and if that
that layer
bursts and goes into your bloodstream
you're dead
and that's what happened to my uncle
you're using heroin as well today yes
which which means you're probably
getting some fentanyl as well
i've dabbled with it but you're probably
getting it in your hair when they
they cut it with them
maybe
i bet you if you were tested you'd find
your yeah
yeah maybe
which makes you more
able to
to to not die as everyone else is doing
when they get fentanyl for the first
time they just
od and die very often
you might be
protected from that because you're
you've eased into your family oh i see
i'm not i'm not telling you you're safe
but no no i don't know i see what you're
saying though there's a lot of heroin
has fentanyl in it okay i see now why
when when
when uh
i do uh when i cause some people they
smoke uh fernando and they go out right
the first second here they go out
and me personally i dabbled with it
about a month ago two months to two
months ago and i overdosed i flatlined i
was i was there i was there on the i was
dead on the uh on the back of the
paramedics for 10 minutes
i was dead they said they
they they pronounced they had pronounced
me dead i mean i was life listening on
the bed they had already shot me up with
the narcon they said not even narcan
brought me back
right but but triple
i strongly believe this is the lord
the the this is the lord
because i don't know if you're spiritual
or not
you're not yeah okay now listen all
these stories
[Laughter]
i've done 3 000 of these
it's hard to believe in anything after
this so you don't believe in god no okay
but before i'm saying before those
stories though but i believe in doing
the right thing
you know basically doing what jesus
would do is is something i would believe
but in terms of
god watching all over over us all i
don't believe it
but do you believe there was a man that
walked on his earth in the name of jesus
yeah probably yeah oh yeah
jesus i believe in a thousand percent
but
with the whole god thing and
it's hard to believe that god would
allow all this stuff to go on
i think about the same thing sometimes
you know like like who who would say
that
so many people getting molested by their
protectors
is okay let's just let that continue
like i would step in if i was god
right
nobody needs to go through that yeah
you're right
it doesn't help anybody
right that's that that is wrong god's
gonna allow that if god is this all
powerful thing yeah that's just wrong
makes it hard to believe right
right i've thought about the same thing
but jesus
i believe a thousand
percent that jesus was on the right
track
but you what do you think but do you
believe that he had powers
no he's just he was just doing the right
thing
okay and he was hated by a lot of people
and loved by so many right
he was just doing the right thing that's
all that was
in in my opinion
it wasn't he was some magical mystical
person like a legend that uh
that god
became a legend basically yeah
because he did the right thing
by everyone
i understand
yeah but me
me personally um
nice saying no
whoa okay so i'm sitting down i i'm
sitting down
i'm laying down dead already
and
in the paramedics truck and the
paramedics that had been dead this is
what the prayer makers told me you know
i have been dead already for 10 minutes
and i don't know where i just
we could you came too yeah it came too
excited you started feeding you started
breathing i started breathing again 10
minutes after i had been dead
and then
like the life just came back in me
like
and i looked and looked around
oh my god i overdosed on
harding you because that wasn't my first
time overdosing
you know fed enough but i also it all
smoked it was fitting off straight you
know
so uh
i had a uh
i had took the first hit first [ __ ] was
cool took the second hit that's when i
remember i just remembered
lining it up
after that i remember
you know what makes you want to even try
fenway
i was just drunk
i was strong
i wasn't thinking but you you know it's
a drug you can kill you very easily yes
yes i know that but
you know when you're drunk you don't
care you don't care about a lot of
things is there a
self-destruct self-destructive streak in
you that's
yes very very very much so yeah yeah i
think we all have it yes
yes
self-destruct the vs perfect perfect
wording
where do you think that comes from
for youth authority
youtube that's what i'm saying youtube
authority doesn't make no things on
better it puts you in a certain
mentality
you know i mean
they you think things are right to do
it's okay to do these things you know
or
uh
not even it's okay to do these things is
you're gonna you could get away with
these things
that's what you say yeah you go insane
yeah i get it yeah they you like it not
not just so that it's cool to do but you
could you could get away with these you
can get away with it if you do it right
yes if you do it right exactly if you do
it the right way you can get it then it
becomes a challenge in the game yes
exactly makes it appealing exactly to a
young man exactly young man yeah as you
get older you realize as you get older
you realize yes
it was all
you were you're a kid you were young and
dumb yeah you know
now you just weren't thinking
yeah because it could have went wrong in
so many ways so many perspectives
you start thinking of so many different
perspectives and yeah you could it could
have went wrong so many ways so many
different ways
you know
but yeah you don't think about that time
you know
it's interesting yes
so where does your life go now you're
you're still young man well i'm 31 right
now uh i'm trying to get back into a a
shelter or housing like i said i was i
was doing good i was clean off heroin
uh i was clean for almost a year really
yeah how'd you get clean from heroin uh
so boxing yeah so boxing helped me get
clean
you know why i got locked up
i got locked up i got out and i wanted
to do it but i knew if i went if i went
down that route i knew i was going to
where i was going to end up at and i
didn't want to go that route
you know so i started dabbling with
suboxone
i mean uh i'm dabbing to take it's
considering medication yeah right
i started taking that
and um
i got clean
but this whole ordeal where the guy
stole from me
messed everything up i got kicked out of
the program i had nowhere to go so
i was back on the streets
a lot of time on my hands nothing to do
coming back and from pointing out a
point a i guess hard to get suboxone
when you're on the street
no it's not hard
i'm just saying it's just
it's hard to stay clean when you're on
the street because all you everything
that's around you and so much time that
you have in your hands
you know what i mean a lot of a lot of
time and everywhere you look
everything is [ __ ] up yes so you might
as well
might as well smoke heroin yes
you know
so i think if you were in an environment
very very different than skid row on
living on the street on skid row maybe
you were in a
some kind of situation where you were
treated with dignity and respect you may
have decided differently right right
but good luck with that
good luck with that they throw you in
the street and you're a piece of crap
yeah
figure it out yeah
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your life
the most
most important thing i've learned in my
life is that
nobody nobody cares about you
nobody's going to take care of you
better than yourself
you know
no nobody
that an old man a wise man once told
me tomorrow
the sun will shine
with or without you
with or without you that sun will come
up tomorrow and shine
so
and you know
nobody's going to take care of
you yourself
better than yourself not your mom
maybe maybe only your mom that's the
only person
right the only your mom but besides your
mother
nobody in this world is going to take
care of better
yourself than yourself not your dad not
your friends because at the end of the
day you don't really got no friends
i mean but when you're in jail whether
where's the money on your books where
where's uh
where's your commissary at where's
where's the phone call that where's the
accepting phone nobody's accepting these
phone calls and when you've got a
self-destructive streak that's pretty
deep
right good luck right good luck
good luck with that
know me
hey
yeah
so the most important thing i i learned
in my life is
you know to take care of yourself you
know what i mean and try to do the right
thing
you know
try to do the right thing because
the wrong thing doesn't leave you to
know we're right
i mean
it won't it never
your mind might tell you this
place it's just a lie
it's a lie
the right thing it's always good to do
the right thing
the the correct thing you know
the right thing
adrian thank you so much for talking
with me
very interesting thank you i wish you
the best of luck i wish you the best as
well thank you i appreciate this
opportunity
you